hi in this video we'll talk about
cryopreservation
cryopreservation is a process that
preserves organelles cells tissues or
any other biological constructs by
cooling the sample to very low
temperatures
now at very low temperature all the
biological activities of the cells stop
now cryo preservation is like a
hibernation mode
when the cell is alive enzymatic
activity gene expression and metabolic
activity is in progress
but when the cell is in cryo
preservation mode all these activities
are
halted now let us look at some
applications
of cryo preservation cryo preservation
could be
used in blood banks seed bank
or even in sperm bank in modern day labs
in order to freeze cell culture we need
to use the
idea of cryopreservation in medical
field
in order to preserve organs or in
agriculture in order to preserve
rare germplasm cryopreservation is a
nice technique so in short
cryopreservation
is very essential in these days
nature is the best cryo preserver
imagine the body of
a woolly mammoth is preserved for
millions
of year under these ice
right but while cryo preservation
is important we need to understand the
risk of
cryo damage when the temperature
surrounding the cell
drops rapidly there is ice crystal
formation
in the cells this can lead to severe
damage to the cell and the cell
eventually dies
but when that temperature drop is
gradual that is also problematic
because the the solvent
surrounding the cell is frozen right now
so the solute concentration really
increase
and lot of water is lost from the cells
and the cells are dehydrated created and
eventually the cells die
what is the solution the solution is to
use
cryoprotectant along with slow freezing
conditions
cryoprotectants are substances which
protect
cells from these kind of freezing
damages and in a moment we would learn
how such chemicals are also known as
antifreeze molecules
some examples are dimethyl sulfoxide
glycerol
or let's say ethylene glycol
now whenever we use cryoprotectant
it increase the solvent concentration so
it kind of balance the increased solus
solute concentration and it prevents ice
crystal formation
so the cells do not die and water loss
can be prevented
and this is how cryoprotectants help and
prevent the cellular death
a quick fact is here so
when you look at the fish which are
surviving
in harsh situations in the polar region
they do have cryoprotectant proteins
in their skills which prevent ice
crystal formation
and that is how they evolved and they
can survive in these
extremely cold conditions now let us
look at
under lab circumstances how we can
perform our cryo preservation
we need a specific media called cryo
protecting media
but before that we need to understand
when is a good time to
freeze the cells the cells need to be
confluent they should be healthy and
their viability should be
greater than 80 so
in a ballpark estimate the cells need to
be at their
log phase of growth curve we need to add
cryoprotectant media which contains dmso
and serum
and then transfer the cell into a
cryoprotectant
container where the temperature drop
would be gradual
and when the temperature reaches minus
80 degree centigrade
then they can be transferred into liquid
nitrogen containing containers
with the temperature is as low as minus
190 degrees centigrade
similar strategies are used in
sperm bank or blood bank now let me tell
you that these cells can be
thought and taken out so
in sperm bank the sperms which are
cryopreserved 10
or even 20 years ago they can be taken
out
and can be thought to perform in vitro
fertilization
that's the biggest advantage so in this
video we learned
that cryo preservation technique could
be beneficial for a healthcare economic
and environmental sectors
if you like this video don't forget to
subscribe
and please check out all my playlist you
can follow me in
instagram or in facebook and do let me
know in the comment if you have any
suggestion or how you like
this video thank you